c'est pratiquement une certitude
aussitôt que le mercure grimpe les
plages et les parcs de toronto
deviennent bondi l'alcool coule parfois
à flot même si sa consommation est
interdite dans les lieux publics avec la
pandémie
des voix s'élèvent pour demander un
assouplissement au règlement municipal
s'est permis ailleurs et c'est beaucoup
plus sécuritaire que de fréquenter les
bars croit cette citoyenne pourtant sur
twitter la ville met en garde les
torontois il s'expose à une amende de
300 dollars s'ils ont des boissons
alcoolisées en leur possession
au cours des derniers jours de nombreux
citoyens ont remarqué une augmentation
de la présence policière dans les parcs
municipaux et sur les plages la police
de toronto n'a pas été en mesure de
dévoiler le nombre de contraventions qui
ont été remises récemment le maire john
tory assure qu'il n'a pas donné la
consigne aux policiers d' entreprendre
un blitz de contraventions il préconise
plutôt la sensibilisation à montréal il
est aussi défendu de consommer des
boissons alcoolisées sur le domaine
public à moins de partager un repas dans
une ère désigné à vancouver un projet
pilote permettra bientôt aux résidents
de consommer dans certains endroits
de quoi rendre les torontois un peu
jaloux et solena l'été et si court
pourquoi ne pouvons nous pas en profiter
dit cet homme
le président croit que les boissons
alcoolisées devrait être tolérée tant
que la situation ne dégénère pas mais
beaucoup se rappellent les débordements
survenus au parc trinity ben woods en
mai dernier
une situation qui avait forcé la ville à
peindre des cercles de distanciation au
sol pas étonnant donc que les autorités
municipales semble hésitant à donner
plus de liberté aux consommateurs
d'alcool ici mathieu simard radio canada
toronto